It is great to welcome to the program today.
Anthony Scaramucci, who is the former White
House communications director, one of one of a
few for the current president, also the founder of
SkyBridge. Anthony, I really appreciate your time.
It's good to be here,
David. Thank you for having me.
So to start with, how did you first enter the
universe of Donald Trump that that even led to you
being in the position of communications director?
So I just interviewed Governor Jeb Bush for
my salt talk series. And I yelled at him
and told me, see, if you had won the
primary and gone on to the presidency,
I wouldn't have been anywhere near the White
House. And so I'm your garden variety fundraiser.
I happened to be hosting Wall Street Week for
the Fox Business Channel in 2016. But I've been
a lifelong Republican fundraiser. I grew up in
a blue collar family. So it was a way for me to
reach a group of people that I would have
never had the opportunity to reach through
the networking of political fundraising. And so
I was working for Jeb Bush. He dropped out of the
race look like then candidate Trump was going to
be the nominee. He called to recruit me. I went
over to see him. I had known him from circles
inside of New York that I know him well. No,
but I knew well enough where we had a
raw, you know, rapport with each other.
We had worked together on the 2012 Mitt Romney
campaign. We had done some fundraising for
Governor Romney. And so I accepted the opportunity
to go work for him. Steve Manoogian and I built
out the architecture for his fundraising. And then
when he won, I was originally supposed to be his
OPL director. But then Reince Priebus and Steve
Bannon didn't want me in the White House. So they
pulled sort of a Washington two step.
I then called President Trump, and this is one
of the classic mistakes. And it's a good learning
lesson for your listeners. Don't put your pride
in your ego into your decision making, because
when you do that, your intelligence goes down and
your emotions go up. And so I made that mistake. I
told President Trump those two guys were bad guys.
If you need me to help you get rid of them, call
me one day. I'll come down and fix it for you.
Next thing you know, on the comms director,
I make a mistake. I say something off color,
which was actually ridiculously funny about
Steve Bannon. I thought I was saying to a friend,
it turned out the guy was a treacherous guy
and he ran over to CNN with a recording of it.
I got fired and frankly, I deserved to be
fired. I shouldn't have put the president or
the administration in that situation. But here's
the silver lining I got out of the White House.
I went back and rebuilt my business. I saved my
marriage. And I created a terrific relationship
with General Kelly, the man that fired me. So
when you're having the ups and downs in life,
just got to keep going. As Winston Churchill said,
when you're walking through hell, keep walking.
So, OK. There's a bunch of things
there I wanted to touch base
about. So one is you mentioned Ben and didn't
want you involved in the White House within.
If I recall the timeline correctly, when you
were announced as White House comms director
Sean Spicer, the timing of Sean Spicer leaving
seemed to coincide with that. It seemed he didn't
want it as well because of it. What is it why
is it that these guys did not want you involved?
Well, I would say, in fairness to Steve, at that
point, I think he was indifferent. I don't think
he cared if I was involved or not. It was really
Dwight's previous rights, previous related one,
anybody from New York that had a rapport with
President Trump to be involved. So that would
have included Chris Christie and Mayor Giuliani,
as well as myself and other New Yorkers. So he had
an unholy alliance. It was an unnatural alliance
because these guys really didn't like each other.
But he had an unholy alliance with Steve Bannon.
And so that's why, if you remember, this is going
back three years ago now. There was tremendous
leaking and tremendous amounts of dysfunctionality
in the White House. And so the president,
in fairness to the president, he deserved
a better staff than that. He deserved people that
were going to try to help him execute his agenda.
But then we learned about the president that he's
not really a great manager. So he can't keep staff
or he has a tendency to rotate through the staff
too quickly. There's no loyalties or allegiances.
And this is why you have this unbelievably
dysfunctional situation that's unfolded for
the United States over the last four years.
What ultimately caused Donald Trump to turn
on you so publicly? Because if I recall
correctly for a little while after you
left it, at least it didn't seem like you
were being antagonized by the president. But
at some point, something changed there.
Well, I mean, I would say that not only
not antagonize, I was very supportive, but I
left the White House. I admitted that I had
made a mistake. I didn't blame anybody for my
firing other than myself. And I was trying to
maintain a level of support and loyalty that the
president, the Republican Party and his agenda
and put, you know, listen, I'm running a business.
I've got to be objective. He's separating women
from children and putting them in cages. Sorry,
I can't subscribe to that. He's disavowing our
intelligence agencies in Helsinki. Can't subscribe
to that. He's calling the press the enemy of the
people. I mean, it's in the First Amendment,
David, for a reason. I can't subscribe to that.
Actually wrote an op ed in April 2019 explaining
why the press is not the enemy of the people.
But I think the piece de resistance for me
was the you went after the four women in the
Congress. Known as the squad. Some of them are
African-Americans. One is a Muslim American. One
is a Hispanic American. He said that they should
go back to the countries that they originally came
from. Three of them were born in the US. One was a
naturalized citizen. All four were democratically
elected to our Congress. That's a ridiculous,
racist, nativist trope. And frankly, David,
they used to say that to my Italian American
grandparents a hundred years ago to go back to
the country that they originally came from. And as
I told Mayor Giuliani, I'm not going to disavow my
personal integrity or market, disavow my family's
history in the United States by supporting that
kind of behavior. So I was on the Bill Marr Show.
I was trying to defend him on the economy and some
of the policies and deregulation. I'm asked about
that. I said, no, that's racism. You should not do
that. So then he started to attack me. That's no
problem. I'm a big boy. If you want to attack me,
I'm a public figure. I know how to handle
myself. I attacked him back then. I call them
Fidel Adolph Trump. I tried to get the fat shaming
in there, you know, the notorious F eighty with
the dictatorship that he's trying to run. He
didn't like that. He hit me again. I hit him
and then he did what he classically does because
he's a complete lowlife. He starts going after my
wife. And so, listen, my wife and I had personal
problems. We almost got divorced as a result of me
working for him. I mean I mean, she dislikes them.
She's doesn't dislike him as much as Malana. Trump
dislikes them. But I mean, she's up there. And
so, you know what what what can I tell you? He
goes after my wife. I mean, now we're in a blood.
Now we're in a cage match. Yeah. You know, I'm not
Ted Cruz. I'm an Italian kid from Long Island. You
don't go after my wife. And so the fight started
and I don't want to see November. The third will
be an interesting referendum for the country and
for Mr. Trump. Let's see what happens. But I think
he's going to get destroyed in that election.
So help me understand when you're although
it was not a long time, but when you were in
the role of White House communications
director from the outside looking in,
we see the constant lying from Donald Trump and
then we see people who are brought in who never
will say it was a lie. They have to sort of clean
it up. We see it with Kelly McEnany. We've we've
seen it with others. What is going on behind the
scenes in terms of are you all among yourselves
saying this guy's lying? How do we clean it
up? Or is there while people are in the role,
you kind of put on a veneer where you don't even
admit to yourself that you're defending lies?
Well, I was there long enough and I only did
one press conference and you can go back and
look at the press conference, I didn't lie
at all in the press covers of Magnolia.
And I wanted to clarify, I mean, like observing
what it's like when he's constantly lying in
public and people have to clean it up.
Well, well, yeah. I mean, that's there's
great frustration related to that. I mean, I was
only there for 11 days, but I can tell you, we're
preparing a speech. He steps into the Rose Garden.
Very good. No form. I don't remember exactly what
it was about, but the number was 86 percent.
He goes into the Rose Garden. He says it's 90
percent comes back into the Oval
Office. Why did you say it was?
90 percent, I mean, 86 percent was a great
amount, and I said 90, 90 is a better number.
And actually it actually isn't, because now you're
gonna get four Pinocchio's from The Washington
Post and it's going to add to this litany of lies.
It's doesn't it's not a good reflection on you.
You know, he'd make hay. He doesn't care. His
point is he's been lying in real estate. He's
been lying in business. He's been lying to his
wives. You've been lying to his children. And
and so his point is, I've gotten away with it's
for so long. Let me double and triple down on
the lie. And if, you know, if you really study
propaganda, you know, what is Joseph Goebbels
say about the lie? The bigger the lie, the more
astounding it is, the more you can get people to
believe it. And so he's got a group of willing
acolytes that will accept what he is saying,
even though you can prove to them that it's a lie.
They'll accept what he's saying. And so for that
and so many other reasons, he's got to go. And
we're working super hard to make that happen.
So yesterday there was an article in Vanity Fair
by Gabriel Sherman where it Gabriel says that
Don Junior in particular, is very worried
about the last 48 hours, worried about the
Corona Caravan around Walter Reed, worried
about the tweets, and that he doesn't want
to be the only one to go in and confront Donald
Trump and say this has to stop. My question is,
are are people afraid of those confrontations?
Because when you hear Trump say the 1917 flew
for six months, it's like, does nobody
go in and say it's 1918 when he says
plasma instead of plasma for six months? Is
that because people are afraid to go in and say,
you know, Mr. President, you're
saying this wrong. This is not right?
Well, I mean, you know, they may say to me he'll
either ignore it or they may just not say to him
because they don't want to get fired. Right. What
he's done in October of twenty nineteen, someone
came to my office at SkyBridge, a senior
cabinet official, a recognizable name globally,
sat on my couch and said, hey, you know, this is
gonna be really bad. I said, well, why is that?
Well, you know, he can't manage anything. And
he's got everybody inside the executive branch
fearing that they're going to be humiliated on
Twitter or he's going to fire them in this public
display of humiliation. So they're not doing
anything. They're all holding back and they're not
coordinating with each other. And so you
need Treasury sometimes to help justice and
justice, sometimes to help the Department of
Homeland Security or the Pentagon to help state.
And everybody's frozen. There's no mechanisms
inside the White House or at the cabinet level
that's creating a symphony of communication among
these departments and cabinet agent subagencies
and so forth. And so if there is a crisis, we
will be immobilized at the top of the government.
We won't be able to handle the crisis. I actually
thought the crisis was the sole remaining strike,
and that happened in January, which now seems
like a thousand years ago. I was looking at that,
thinking of the what that senior cabinet official
said to me in my office. I said, oh, my God,
this is going to be it. Thankfully, cooler heads
prevail there. But it turned out the real crisis
was covered 19. He was not capable of handling it.
He lives in this reality distortion field. He's
trying to force the people around him to live in
that distortion field, which is why so many good
people have left the administration or been fired
by him because they won't abide by his nonsense.
And so he's now he's now there with a group of
spineless sic sycophants inside the White House,
and he's lying through his teeth. He lied about
the science. He lied about mass wearing. He
couldn't coordinate a unified strategy with the
states to bring down the virus. And so the great
irony is the economy. Which was the cornerstone of
his reelection campaign because of his malfeasance
and his malpractise and his poor decision making,
he destroyed the economy. And so we're sitting
here right now. We've got a guy who's incompetent.
We have a guy that is overcompensating for
something. We got a guy that looked like he was in
a satire. It was almost like a Sacha Baron Cohen
satire comedy yesterday of an Eastern European
dictator trying to create a propaganda film.
And that's where we are right now in America.
But CNN is saying 57 41, Joe Biden, Wall Street
Journal, NBC saying 54, you know, 42 to Joe Biden.
Maybe those polls are oversample for Democrats.
I don't know. I don't trust the polling anymore
that anybody should trust the polling. We have to
run through the tape here and beat him on Election
Day. So hopefully we'll do that. I think the good
news. Oh, sorry. Go ahead. Yeah. Well, he's just
the last statement. The good news for the American
people, he's the polarizing candidate this time
while people will go out and vote against him.
My entire interview with Anthony
Scaramouch, he White House communications
director for a brief period of time under
Donald Trump and founder of SkyBridge,
will be on the YouTube channel in full YouTube dot
com slash The David Pakman Show on the podcast.
TV and radio show will go to a quick
break and be back right after this.